&gt;&gt; So here's the word equation we came up with in the last problem. Clearly
though, considering I had to write this on two separate lines, there are a lot
of words here and this is going to be kind of confusing to keep track of. So,
let's use some different variables. I'd like to let x equal the number of
nozzles made and I'd like to let y equal the total amount spent on nozzle
production. So, with those substitutions, our equation will look a little bit
cleaner. With these substitutions, it's pretty clear that this equation is
written in slope intercept form, which we are now very familiar and comfortable
with. So thinking about where the slope should show up in this equation and the
information that we're given. What number do you think the slope is equal to in
this equation?